les nantais
[Musique]
depuis le début de la guerre en ukraine
vladimir poutine justifie son opération
militaire en disant vouloir des natifs y
est le pays mais pourquoi at il utilisé
ce terme est ce qu'il y a réellement des
nazis en ukraine on vous explique tout
dans facture
avant de se pencher sur l'histoire
contemporaine il faut d'abord revenir
quelques décennies en arrière et zoomer
sur une carte d'europe nous sommes en
1939 à l'aube de la seconde guerre
mondiale l'allemagne et l'union
soviétique signent un pacte de non
agression qui inclut l'invasion de la
pologne et son partage
l'allemagne prend la partie occidentale
de la pologne et l'union soviétique la
partie orientale en 1941 l'allemagne
brise cet accord attaque l'urss à
travers l'opération barbarossa et ce qui
nous intéresse plus particulièrement
c'est qu'elle conquiert la galicie cette
région à cheval entre la pologne et
l'ukraine actuelle et c'est à ce moment
là que stepan bandeira intervient mais
qui est il
stepan bandera est un militant
nationaliste ukrainien
a fondé en 1941 alors l'armée
insurrectionnelle d'ukraine qui sera une
milice de ce mouvement qui va donc
collaborer avec l'allemagne avant d'être
réprimées et à cette époque là les
mouvements nationalistes ukrainiens
s'allie avec l'allemagne nazie
la déclaration d'indépendance de
l'ukraine proclamé en 1941 précise
d'ailleurs que l'état ukrainien
coopèrera avec la grande allemagne
national socialiste sous la direction de
son chef adolf hitler
stepan banderas sera empoisonné par un
agent ukrainien du kgb 18 ans plus tard
plusieurs décennies après certains
ukrainien rend encore hommage à stéphane
bandeira jusqu'à la révolution de maiden
en 2014
cette période de protestation a permis à
l'ukraine d'avancé sur plusieurs
réformes pro mieux mais d'autre part le
mouvement aura laissé place à la
violence et à la montée de bataille en
volontaires nationalistes dans les
événements de 2014 donc le soulèvement
[Musique]
anti-russe de maidan
effectivement les groupuscules néo-nazis
ont joué un rôle dans le soulèvement
parce qu'il y avait un certain nombre de
hooligans qui était
qui était intégrée party ce mouvement et
qui avaient une expérience de
des barricades de se battre
dans un combat urbain
en 2014 toujours le bataillon azoff
reprend la ville de mario paul aux
séparatistes pro russes et c'est ce qui
leur permettra par la suite d'être
intégré à la garde nationale ukrainienne
soit l'équivalent de la gendarmerie
française
le régiment azoff a été critiqué pour
avoir utilisé plusieurs symboles nazis
comme le wave sans qu'elle ait dans le
bataillon oiseaux en fait il ya un noyau
qui est
qui et néonazis autour duquel s'est
agrégée rien espèce de mouvement
nationaliste
donc c'est comme si on disait que le fn
en raw est un parti
aux élections législatives de 2012 le
parti nationaliste appelé svoboda
liberté en français représenté 10% des
votes soit deux millions de suffrages
pour 45 millions d'habitants à l'époque
jusqu'en 2003 le logo du parti était un
dérivé du wolf s'engueulent utilisé par
la deuxième division ss dans les années
lors des élections présidentielles de
2014 ils ne représentaient que 1 16% des
votes et aujourd'hui quand on regarde la
répartition des sièges au sein de la
rada le parlement ukrainien
on se rend compte que ce parti n'a qu'un
seul siège
revenons en maintenant au terme de
dénazification qui vient tout droit du
champ lexical de la seconde guerre
mondiale et plus exactement celui de la
conférence de potsdam en 1945 conférence
où les alliés en statuer sur le devenir
de l'allemagne nazie et ont mis en place
sur la politique des sondés et à quoi
correspond cette politique des cinq des
ans le caillou craignant elle
correspondrait à la dénazification la
démocratisation la déterritorialisation
la démilitarisation et là des
cartellisation
vladimir poutine à faire un lien direct
entre l'histoire contemporaine de
l'ukraine et celle de l'europe à la
sortie de la seconde guerre mondiale la
russie a livré bataille contre le
fascisme a payé un lourd tribut et est
en grande partie alors responsable de la
victoire sur l'allemagne nazie donc
partant de cela il y à cette idée que
toute invasion tentative d'invasion en
provenance de l'ouest est forcément
d'origine fasciste et que la russie doit
à nouveau reprendre son rôle historique
de d'ennemi mortel du fascisme